hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Sara Hewson Kevin McGuire and Roy
anika are here to look back at the
biggest stories of the past seven days
so what were your top stories of the
week Roy mine has to be the MP David
Winnick calling philip green billionaire
spife who ashamed british capitalism i'm
kevin i think it's got to be the
campaign to try and free mosul as many
millions of people trapped you want to
see the back of the Islamic state but
you fear the casualties okay well that
is our top story this week a coalition
of the Iraqi army and Peshmerga launched
an assault on Iraq's second city mosel
in an attempt to drive out Islamic state
the attacks focused on the towns of bash
eeka bar teller and the village of noir
on skies chief correspondent Stewart
Ramsey joined Iraq's elite golden
division on the road to bart Ella we
joined golden divisions Humvees edging
their way down the main road Bartel town
and the start of the battlefield proper
the mosel brigade is tasked with
clearing the road ahead to the town
center we're right at the front
this is urban fighting and it was always
going to be like this there are pockets
of Islamic state everywhere
well it's no bother as the soldiers
identify targets hey open despite their
firepower the incoming rounds are a
constant it was with us all day dodging
to take cover we're attacked from two
sides the Iraqis respond we know the
convoy is being targeted by suicide
bombers in cars then they strike in
front of us so Stuart Ramsay they're
demonstrating the level of resistance
that they are encountering on the road
to Mosul and yet the Iraqi p.m. is
saying that this is going faster than
they had anticipated Kevin they may
regret that in due course if the
resistance is tougher than he then he
says it's supposed to trying to raise
morale of his own troops and and people
but the Islamic state as we know that
that dogged and they will fight all the
way and it's the the civilians who you
fear will be used as human shields and
also you're going to have shears going
in you could have Kurds going in there's
going to be a lot of tension on the
ground I'm Roy on that's the subject of
civilians I mean one to one-and-a-half
million civilians in Mosul where do they
go and and around 600,000 children has
been estimated I mean that's the problem
once again we have this awful situation
like in Aleppo in Syria where civilians
are faced with that awful position do
they stay put and face horrendous
bombardment and being used as as shields
which we know Isis do or do they leave
and then where do they go we know
there's a huge humanitarian crisis in
Aleppo where the refugees go it's a
horrendous humanitarian situation
developing there yeah and we had this
leaflet dropping exercise didn't we buy
the military saying stay in your homes
stay low down I mean decision to make
to whether to stay or go is just one
that none of us would wish to ever have
to make no that could be a life-or-death
decision in it so you stay in your home
but have you got food have you got water
and the sanitary conditions must be must
be appalling that people will be
genuinely terrified and you just hope
this is over as quickly and as
painlessly as possible yeah absolutely
well that is our top story in a busy
news week and here are five things you
might have missed police revealed the
ten most wanted Britons on the run in
Spain leading to one arrest within hours
among them are people accused of fraud
drug offenses and murder detectives
think they're living among expats on the
continent their photos will be placed on
buses and plane boarding passes among
them is Mark acklam he's a serial con
man accused of stealing eight hundred
and fifty thousand pounds from a
divorcee whom he told he was a Swiss
banker thousands of gay and bisexual men
who were convicted of sexual offenses
which have now been abolished are going
to be posthumously pardoned following a
campaign led by the Liberal Democrats
the move comes after Second World War
code breaker Alan Turing was given a
posthumous royal pardon in 2013 over a
conviction in 1952 for gross indecency
all men who were prosecuted under the
criminalization of homosexuality will be
exonerated for what should never have
been a crime in the first place MP is
called for former BHS owners to Philip
Green to be stripped of his knighthood
the high street chain collapsed in April
costing 11,000 jobs and 22,000
pensioners were hit by a 571 million
pound black hole in the pension funds
London Zoo have revealed just what an
escaped gorilla got up to during his
time on the run kombucha had gone
through two unlocked doors last week
leading the zoo to be put on lockdown
during his escape it's turned out that
the 29 stone primates downed five liters
of undiluted squash before he was
tranquilized presumably as much fun as
sugar crash as anything else
and now for our gap of the week it has
to go to the Olympic parade in
Manchester which wit missed two wanna be
heroes sneaking onto a float pretending
to be medalist the pair were rumbled by
our sports correspondent Paul Kelso what
did you win so that was the Olympics oh
that sounds offensive in the Olympics
yeah yeah yeahs blagging Olympics was it
a bit of one a bit of one year we just
kind of what medal oh yeah so we will
see what the medal and we just thought
you know I'll give it her we actually
got oh she don it was actually
completely against our will follow you
you're a couple of bloggers on you ya
like like something every now and then
but so would you give them a gold medal
for blogging yeah great work by kelsye
with the yard there Sicily melt oh they
were I was thinking about this would
I've got it I think might have been a
bit gullible yeah I'd have been afraid
of challenging them and they were
genuine and you're questioning somebody
they say don't you know and talk about
fencing yeah the pinnacle of their sport
their world it's often gonna gold medal
day for the outfits I mean they done
well no well I mean it is a plastic
medal isn't it yeah I managed to get on
to the these flows they said that they
didn't try that hard they just kind of
got a big board a tracksuit bought a
fake medal and got uh [ __ ] on I don't
need ariat gold for cheek you're gonna
admire yeah absolutely I don't forget
send us your nominations using the
hashtag w in our well this week it was
revealed that more than two-thirds of
child refugees trying to enter the UK
who had their age assessed in the year
to june were found to be adults the
Conservative MP has suggested that
dental checks should be carried out on
all new arrivals skies David Bowden
reports to buy to the next small group
of migrants from the jungle camp in
Calais stepped off the coach in Croydon
and into a new life in the UK all the
newcomers deemed to be officially
unaccompanied minors under
eighteen-years-old but there are
questions about whether
some of those who came earlier in the
week were considerably older on this bus
seventeen-year-old khaled sharrouf from
dara in Syria and there to meet him to
other 17 year olds from his hometown his
cousin Ahmed and friend Mohammed who'd
received a text from colored telling him
he was on his way he's just arrived on
the earth yeah and how old is he 17 and
where where is he from originally Syria
whereabouts in Syria da-da-da-da-da and
is that where you are from yeah and how
old are you certainty and how long have
you been here in the UK oh yeah despite
the controversy over the age of some of
the migrants that have already arrived
here in Croydon from Calais there's
little doubt from my untrained eye that
those that arrived this time were
children know exactly how old each of
them was it's impossible to say the home
office ruled out a tour EMPs idea of
using dental check to determine the true
age of the migrants but experts say it
would work anyway so far the UK has
taken just a few dozen young migrants
from the jungle camp in cali thousands
more of all ages are still hoping to
cross the channel how do we get around
this issue of age because these are
people without papers it's very
difficult to know where they've come
from how old they are the suggestion was
made that they should go through dental
checks but that is pretty very
controversial yeah and I totally agree
with the British identification I think
we should be doing that I think it is a
bit unethical spec'ed i see i don't know
i mean it shows how the assistive there
to be possibly exploited and we know
given the jungle cam was going to be
destroyed this one was going to be
exacerbated I don't know what the
government is going to suggest but it's
clearly going to be a problem i mean
there's this idea that some countries
use x-rays of risk to sort of look at
bone density which could be more
reliable than looking at teeth or people
expecting them becoming clutching teddy
bears and comfort blankets from the from
the cart i think i'm in correspondent
who was there on the first day when they
arrived in quantum assailant
photographers were waiting there for the
pictures those images iconic images of
children unaccompanied children arriving
and
these teenagers arrived and they yeah
and they were expecting kids of eight or
nine or whatever and you got kids who
are mid teens oh how often are you
surprised by how old somebody is you
look at them and they tell you they're
their age and you say I thought you were
a lot older it pubs are dealing with
this all the time clubs are dealing with
this also i watch i watch kids play
would be in football and you're amazed
they're taller than me I'm six foot so
system that we're operating under there
isn't it it's based on appearance yeah
and demeanor but the home underneath in
the last year found that two-thirds of
those who came into this country were
over at the age of 18 no that was
two-thirds of those who were challenged
right two heads of those is not of the
overall number so a third of those who
are challenged were wrongly wrongly
challenge and yes of course you know
some people will they've been through
desperate times will lie about their age
that's you know just common sense some
will do that but I say why we're
demonizing all kids because of this and
all refugees I think interviews and
tests in some way that absolutely fine
but there are some people and you can
smell the racism just don't want anybody
to come in and they're using this to try
and undermine the entire system okay
quick quiz for you now can you tell me
why it might be curtains for one alleged
would-be thief don't know we'll find out
after the break welcome back to week in
review with me Sarah Hewson i'm joined
by kevin maguire associate editor of The
Daily Mirror and journalist Roya Nika
well before the break we asked why it
might be curtains for one alleged
would-be thief let's have a look this is
brilliant isn't it mm this chap is
suspected of trying to steal a venetian
blind it's that's not in the most subtle
manner I don't and what was going
through his head if he thought that this
was going to be okay he tried to hide it
he stuffed it down his trousers and his
jacket and northamptonshire police said
staff chased him they caused him to drop
the blind while he was
away so anyway looks open and shut yeah
no bad for you you wouldn't you wouldn't
want him on your pub quiz team if he's
that daft would you the two candidates
are vying for the keys to the Oval
Office was certainly in combative mood
during the third and final TV debate in
the night's most controversial moment
Donald Trump refused to promise that he
would accept the election result if he
lost skies us correspondent Cordelia
Lynch reports a gladiatorial finale in
Sin City and two bitter rivals skipping
another handshake Hillary Clinton tried
to divert mounting questions about
leaked emails by calling on Trump to
renounce Russian hackers I actually
think the most important question of
this evening Chris is finally will
Donald Trump admit and condemn that the
Russians are doing this and make it
clear that he will not have the help of
Putin in this election that he rejects
Russian espionage against Americans
which he actually encouraged in the past
those are the questions we need answered
we've never had anything like this
happen in any of our elections before
the billionaire businessman dismissed
the allegations of sexual assault
against him and the women who have made
them those stories are all totally false
i have to say that and i didn't even
apologize to my wife who's sitting right
here because i didn't do anything I
didn't know any of these women I didn't
see these women these women the woman on
the plane the one I think they want
either fame or her campaign did it and I
think it's her campaign but one answer
will dominate his refusal to commit to a
result part for the good of the country
are you saying you're not prepared now
to Quantico sayin chiz that I will tell
you at the time I'll keep you in
suspense so where do we begin with this
and let's start with the Donald Trump
saying he'll keep us in suspense as to
whether I'll accept the result or not
although he then came out and said well
it will accept the result if I win yeah
I think he's in a hole and he digs
himself deeper because that will just
turn
off or what kind of decent Americans who
think like you have a contest you win
you win you lose you lose and he just
won city's entire way and he exposes his
bad temperament and why he would be a
lousy president I totally agree i think
someone coming out and saying they're
not going to respect the democratic
process in America it's brilliant Ashley
because it will turn off a lot of people
who probably wavering but I think the
problem here is if I was an American
citizen I would be really depressed by
my two options there is a major trust
issue with Hillary Clinton that that
Trump has just gone for every single
time and it works and rings true and
makes American people think what was so
bad that she had to hide sixteen
thousand emails and that's the problem
me it's been an Achilles heel throughout
let's move on to your choices of top
paper stories for the week and Roya
you've started with one at that is there
I i can imagine we're going to get a
good response to this one from you Kevin
angry women drivers I can try and stay
very calm here I find the study really
irritating this is a study done by
Goldsmiths University that claims that
women are twelve percent more likely to
be annoyed when they're undertaken when
people don't indicate all those kind of
things I just think this is ridiculous
first of all it's done my man this study
what a great surprise secondly all those
things annoy men just as much and it's
one of those studies that winds me up
because I it feeds into the stereotypes
men going Oh women drivers actually if
you read into this study a little bit
more it goes back to the fact that women
back in the stone Age's what we're
always trying to protect their young
when men went out to go into it with
gabbling let me read you I'm not going
to gang up on you Kevin because I notice
two against one but that's unusual yeah
absolutely inherent sexism in this
situation just want to read you one
quote from the report it says
psychologically women score higher than
men on emotional and verbal intelligence
oh how sweet I mean that's true that
bitch'll story is very don't mind a bit
doing it even it was written by a man
but I have noticed a rise in when women
drivers giving you the coffee bean shake
oh yeah the figure that's it's probably
greater equality men men i would say
overall are still worse by can see the
Saudi regime taken this report to
justify their not allowing women to
drive you
rageous i'll be dancing the streets of
reared well the men willing and on the
subject of angry words you Kip have been
many this week yeah the old broad
continues and Steven wolf quit son
governor ball you capiz the MEP who was
involved in what the altercation with
that mic right hukum in which steven
wolf ended up in in hospital he says he
quitting because of the invite who's
been involved in the only physical fight
we know of but you can see that party is
just falling apart they've lost their
deposit in the Whitney by-election and I
think with mount Nigel Farage and he's
personality whatever you thought about
it and we could impose a form of
discipline on that rabble it's gone and
he is now at the helm again until they
find on you forever you feel like he's
just never going to leave I just bounces
back every time for eyes without as they
all fall by the wayside but it is
incredible you'll be on his way to the
Tories wolf he did figure defecting
they'll have him stuffed mounted and use
them as a trophy that wolf and a big
issue for the Tories coming up next week
royer Heathrow expansion ministers are
be given the right to assert their
protest yeah and this this decision
apparent is finally apparently coming
next week and Theresa May has told
colleagues in the cabinet that there's
going to be a set period where ministers
can sort of voice their opposition to it
which a implies that it's a better
company and they're going to decide that
there will be a third runway at heathrow
but it doesn't it there's no clarity on
whether or not MPs are gonna be allowed
to vote actually vote on the decision um
I think the main issue here I think is
really appalling actually is that there
is the committee that decides makes
decision next week with with trading on
it there is no London MP on that
committee and I think that's appalling
actually yeah well it's to get the
results you what time I think the will
be you she'll have to concede a vote at
the end do you think he's more about my
boys his King he's gonna lie down in
front of bulldozers it you know if it
goes ahead I don't and now he's
backtracking what will he do Johnson
will do what is best for Johnson as he
always did and he did say he'd lie down
in front of bulldozers he's not going to
resign as foreign secretary he'll mumble
of
it and then you'll just go along with it
but he is allowed that short period of
time to a certain search remotest in
cabinet and Kevin you picked out an
interesting story about unisex changing
rooms yeah this is a this is a sports
club in Chelsea which is going to get
rid of male and female and have a
village we're using both now this
happens in some some leisure centres but
a lot of people who use it particularly
women say it I don't want to be seen
going from the shower with a towel
around them in front of it and i agree i
when i gave up journalism went the
guardian for six years they had a party
and in in a kind of club once i still
can't get over the the sight of Polly
Toynbee in the unisex toilet something
she probably gone get over their sight
of me in there as well you can't you
yeah I mean I up some things bars have
tried at unisex toilets haven't they but
the changing rooms because I think
that's fine i think the changing rooms
I'm all for equality where appropriate
but I just think I think women would
feel really uncomfortable and if that's
going to be rented people going to the
gym here that's really bad just about
covering yourselves it's about men and
male etiquette in the changing sometimes
that's strutting around you know look in
town not currently document war stomach
what you mean the big swinging Richard
act don't something I mean there come on
Scooby no I'm not sure that's what I
want when I found you know swim but you
would go for mixed toilet but I mean
don't bury their doors Kevin go dear
never worked in alley McBeal where I
used to watch that cool let's look at
your ups and downs for the week and roy
out we're starting with a legend Chuck
Berry what a total dude John Lennon want
said if you tried to keep rockin rollin
on the name you might try calling it
Chuck Berry and in this case absolutely
right at the age of 90 he's releasing
his first new album since 1979 which i
think is incredibly cool your tax bill
was dedicated he's a gazillionaire he's
dedicating it to his wife of 68 years a
toddy which I think like she's 60 is
totally which i think is brilliant and I
just think he said to her you know what
darling I'm gonna hang my boots off this
but this one's for you and I think he's
a total dude for doing it all yes so if
we don't have a date for the release of
the album early 2017 but we talk about
him as the founding father of
rock'n'roll
and i read that that becomes all the
more relevant when you realize that the
rolling stones were formed because Mick
Jagger saw Keith Richards holding a
chuck berry record on a railway station
platforming well and that is how they
came together facing history all right
I'll start take it back get back we're
sending him out at down though not a
good week for the Mars mission not a
good week for the European Space Agency
again deja vu scaparelli which sort of
floated through the Martian atmosphere
and came so close then just completely
disappeared as it was due to touch down
and then we had you know we had beagle
to a few years ago exactly the same or
similar thing happened I disagree which
was missing for many many years it was
only a couple of years ago that they d
actually managed to discover what had
happened to it I think it's brilliant
these attempts are being made because it
hasn't technology instead of space
discovery come so far but I think this
must be master saying I don't want to be
explored yet but all that work if your
scrap metal dealer get there now is it's
easily format support given isn't it but
is so we're sending the Mars mission and
down Kevin that you are calling out a
woman who called out the cat callers in
Northland yeah this is courtney a great
Rick's 22 in London walking to the tube
and three blokes in her van they were
roofers began whistling out shouting
obscene things not out gestures or
ringing a bell he thought it was funny
and she took she took a picture put it
online one of them has been sat the
other two are being investigated a good
to her you shouldn't have to suffer this
abuse and a few weeks ago on a week in
review we discussed how Joanna Lumley
said Oh wolf-whistling is great well I
on this is an extension of that and it's
not great women shouldn't have to put up
with a abusiveness yeah she's called
them out and I think she said don't
worry boys wolf whistling from your
company car means your boss is about to
find out all about it punchy like her
smart yeah so we're sending her up and
down Julian Assange she's had his
internet access cut off yeah in the air
London embassy the equity the
Ecuadorians and it's because he's been
WikiLeaks has ceased to have some access
with Russians to try and dune doing
Hillary Clinton they've never really
gone after Donald Trump so they've cut
off is
isn't a net access which would be
terrible for him you can always pop
outside couldn't me you might get a
better signal be alright but I I like
with you yeah but I've been an interview
in the Ecuadorian Embassy and its small
space is very limited what what's he
doing without internet access who cares
I'm out yes Justice Kennedy's even there
for more than four you get on a flight
sweden constantly coming this week
weren't there that's been delayed until
november they weren't gonna be allowed
to question him it was the Ecuadorians
who are going to question when they
would give the answers to the Swedes but
the way they're women in in Sweden of
being treated as a poorly but he is a
supporter just abusing them if anyone
else was accused of sexual assault and
rape you will be on a plan to get there
clear your name he's hiding he's got a
terrible sense of self and he says
they'll send into the US and he won't
get a fair trial there but what are
sending julian assange goose down yeah
don't forget send us your nominations
using the hashtag w in our that's all
we've got time for thank you for joining
us for our review of the week we'll be
back for more next week but for now it's
goodbye from them goodbye and it's
goodbye from me goodbye